[Musique]
retour en Bourgogne pour la suite de
notre édition spéciale au lendemain du
premier tour des élections
départementales en Bourgogne donc nous
détaillerons les résultats avec Elsa
Besin vous les retrouvez également sur
notre site internet france3.fr Lilian
Melay et Eric SIO sont également avec
nous pour analyser ces résultats et
questionner nos invités pour le Parti
socialiste Michel neot est là bonjour
bonjour premier secrétaire fédéral du
Parti en côe d'or et puis pour l'UMP
Alain sugn député de côe d'or bonjour à
vous merci d'être avec nous puis
d'autres réactions également dans le
courant de cette émission depuis nos
studios à haosser never Macon et le
creusau puis noté en fin d'émission un
débat sur l'canton de Montbar entre
Laurence sportte et Patrick Molino la
mère de Montbar devance le candidat
sortant du PRG commençons par un
département où le rapport de force reste
incertain celui de la sonnéloire
illustration dans le canton de Louan
celui du président socialiste sortant
Rémy chintron les candidats sont
repartis en campagne dès ce matin Damien
boutiller et Romi wach le marché de
Louan avec sa centaine de commerçants et
ses milliers de promeneurs et
d'acheteurs c'est un lieu incontournable
de la vie bressane mais surprise en ce
lundi matin d'entre de tour des
élections départementales il n'y a pas
de serrage de main des candidats
qualifié pour le second tour pas de
surprise là ils se reposent maintenant
ils sont ils ont ce qu'il fallait quoi
ils sont pas réveillés ils ont passé la
nuit ils sont
fatigués tout simplement il y a des
contents pu des mécontents mais en fa
pourtant les candidats sont bien en
campagne mais aujourd'hui ils ne font
pas de terrain à l'instar de l'UMP on
laisse les gens en parler et faire le
bilan eux-même voilà on va paser
déranger et on va sûrement essayer
d'aller voir certains abstentionistes
parce que même si ici y a une belle
mobilisation il a encore voilà des gens
qui sont pas allés voter et rappeler que
c'est un enjeu local même sil y un
message fort au niveau national qui
était lancé il faut rappeler que les
élections de B c'est des enjeux locaux
donc voilà que les gens choisissent leur
représentant quant à Rémy chintron il
est aux abonnés absents il s'est isolé
des caméras et des médias pourécrire la
profession de foi de son binôme mais dès
hier soir il tirait les enseignements du
premier tour je crois que effectivement
on paye aussi une certaine défiance
vis-à-vis du Parti socialiste je n'ai
jamais caché mon étiquette j'ai toujours
ma carte et et je la garderaiis j'ai
déjours dit que j'étais plus socialiste
que beaucoup d'autres et donc c'est vrai
que ça va être c'est un deuxème tour
compliqué mais vous savez en politique
on a l'habitude des deuxième tours
compliqués et donc on va tout faire pour
rattraper le retard même si c'est vrai
qu'il est important ainsi à gauche la
pilu a du mal à passer car même à
montrer où sa colissière Sabine Cheffer
est maire le PS est
battu les résultats dans le département
de sonelloir Elsa avec donc d'abord
Louan oui Louan en résultat très
important le président sortant vient de
le voir Remmy chintron est en mauvaise
posture le socialiste n'est pas sûr
d'être réélu son binôme est devancé par
celui de la droite en revanche la gauche
résiste à Cluny Cluny où le tandem
Jean-Luc fonrait ellisabethe leemonon
est le seul binôme socialiste élu au
premier tour en brocon c'est un cas
unique affaire réglé aussi pour deux
autres cantons la droite est élue à
chauffaille vous le voyez la droite
s'impose également à charol on va
prendre maintenant la direction de
saint-valler où il y a à dimanche
prochain un duel gauche gauche ce sera
un affrontement Front de Gauche Parti
socialiste à Digouin cette fois la
gauche est malmenée c'est le cas aussi
dans d'autres canton de son et Loire
comme Chalon 2 où on se dirige vers un
duel droite gauche au 2ème tour même
situation dans les cantons d'autin et de
montsaumes la gauche est en difficulté
elle sera face à la droite un dernier
résultat pour ce département celui de la
chapelle de gincher la droite victime de
ces divisions arrive derrière 2uxè
derrière le Front national chapelle de
ginchet où le coup de poker de Gérard
voisin n'a donc pas fonctionné l'UMP est
au deuxème tour avec le FN en tête sur
ce canton le binome socialiste lui est
éliminé Stéphane Robert et Gabriel t il
est un peu plus de 18h Jean-François
Cognard n'en attendait pas moins très
largement en tête dans sa commune le
candidat du binôme UMP udi écrase le duo
dissident de droite et devance assez
largement le Front national plus tard à
la chapelle de ginché à l'inverse de
chintteré une tendance se dégage le FN
arrive en tête et s'impose même dans
cette ville de 4000 habitants résultat
confirmé pour l'ensemble du canton
Carole à la mererie et Serge Papion avec
29,28 % des voix sont en tête face au
binô umpudi qui recueille un peu plus de
27 % des voix on attend le deè tour
aussi parce que rien ne bougera si au 2è
tour le vent tourne et et qu'on arrive
pas en tête donc ça sert à rien de se
précipiter c'est très bien pour le
premier tour vraiment très très contente
mais on va continuer et puis on va
attendre voir si si ça se concrétise le
binôme soutenu par la majorité
départementale n'ayant pas atteint les
12,5i % des inscrit é éliminé à l'issue
de ce premier tour retour à chintteré au
QG de campagne de Jean-François Cognard
ambiance beaucoup plus détendu le maire
de chintteray espère maintenant une
victoire dimanche prochain pour le le
deè tour
il faut qu'on se rassemble on l'avait
dit que moi je l'avais dit la dernière
fois que je vous ai vu que la droite se
rassemble j'espère qu'on va se
rassembler on sait très bien que le FN a
fait le plein au premier tour et que
maintenant et je je compte même sur le
PS le PS va ne votera pas ne votera pas
pour le Front national c'est clair le
front le Front républicain va va va se
mettre en marche ça va marcher et on
peut pas laisser le Front national
commander le département Gérard voisin
avec près de 13 % des voix dans cette
candidature dissidente est éliminée
vexé par sa suspension de l'UMP
appellera-t-il à voter pour le binô
umpudi et plus largement cette nouvelle
défaite marque-t-elle la fin d'une
carrière politique riche l'ancien maire
de Charnet les maacon n'a pas souhaité
commenter ses
résultats résultats analyse et débat ce
midi sur France 3 Bourgogne avec nos
invités éco oui benah d'abord une
première question peut-être sur la
situation en sonéloir à vous Michel not
en tant que premier secrétaire du PS de
d'à côté hein de de cô d'or on voit le
président de sonir qui quand même très
affaibli mais une gauche qui résiste qui
est toujours en tête le bloc de gauche
est toujours en tête en sonnelloire
malgré tout est-ce que la perte de ce
département serait ne serait pas une
catastrophe pour vous en tant que
département on peut dire symbolique
puisque ça a été celui d'arna Montebourg
notamment bah toute perte de département
détenu par la gauche est une difficulté
qu'il faudra asser mais on n'est pas
dans ce cas de figure déjà ce que l'on
peut remarquer c'est que il y a une plus
forte mobilisation que prévue et et il
semble que cette mobilisation c'était
des mobilisations d'électeurs de gauche
qui finalement se sont retrouvés pour
assurer des scorses meilleurs dans les
quatre départements Bourignon notamment
en côe d'or que ce que nous envisagions
et ce que on nous prédisait donc je
crois que les clés du deuxè Tour c'est
déjà le rassemblement c'est le rassembl
de la gauche et la clarté du langage que
l'on porte c'est-à-dire que il y a le
Front National et tout ces risques qu'il
met sur le bien vivre ensemble c'està
dire c'est une société éclatée qu'il
nous promet c'est sont des mesures de
régression forte et puis a la politique
de la droite qui là où elle est aux
affaires au niveau du département assume
une sorte de régression sociale et ce
que l'on veut dans ce deuxème tour c'est
concrètement expliquer que le départte
les départements
sa quand même à plus des 2 tiers de la
solidarité avec nos concitoyens
générationnelle et c'est aussi de la
célérité territoriale et donc c'est
c'est cela qui compte et la gauche est
là pour l'assurer comme l'assurance son
Loire et ça va jouer vous savez un ou
deux sièges donc rien n'est perdu rien
n'est perdu et situation très serré
c'est serré Mo s'y attendait on on
disait même que c'était perdu d'avance
d'après tous les sondages donc on est
après un premier tour où c'est serré
rien n'est perdu en sonéloir et je pense
que on gagnera al SuG quelle est votre
vision vous de ce qui se passe en
sonnéloire je voudrais déjà Michel denux
a tendance à minimiser ce qui risque
d'être une catastrophe c'est vrai que si
la
sonnéloire tombait pour le Parti
socialiste automatiquement ça serait à
l'échelle de la Bourgogne je pense la
preuve de cette déroute qui n'est pas
encore réalisé mais la suite de la
défaite de dimanche soir donc
aujourd'hui il faut bien sûr mobiliser
les troupes et en saéloire notamment
mais c'est aussi valable en Côte d'Or je
crois qu'il y a des triangulaires il est
nécessaire au-delà de donner l'invective
en disant que les électeurs se sont
trompés et qu'ils ont voté pour les
mauvais candidats ou les mauvaises
listes n'ampêche qu'aujourd'hui il faut
peut-être que le gouvernement se
ressaisisse et ne prenne pas les mesures
que l'on connaît depuis maintenant 3 ans
qui aboutissent à des votes extrêmes
c'est aussi simple que ça donc la
saloire fait partie aujourd'hui de ces
départements mais content et je pense
que dimanche prochain ça m'étonnerait
pas que la séloire rejoigne la nouvelle
majorité dans ce pays c'est-à-dire l'UMP
l'UDI et les indépendants la situation
en sonloir à gauche avec l' au creusau
de Jean-Luc fon il nous rejoint depuis
notre bureau France 3 au creusau élu sur
le canton de Clun face à la droite je
dis creo c'est Cluni bien sûr mais en
direct du creau pour parler du canton de
Clun et de la son noire en général
Jean-Luc font et lu avec 52 % des voix
hier au premier tour bonjour Merci
d'être en direct avec nous donc
configuration différente dans votre
contemp avec cette élection pour vous
dès le premier
tour
bonjour et c'est une surprise pour vous
cette élection dès le prier vous êtes le
seul en Bourgogne élu de gauche à être
réélu c'est la prime au sortant
oui sans doute primo sortant après un
travail de terrain de proximité et une
déclinaison permanente de des travaux et
des décisions de la majorité
départementale de ce
département alors il y a une égalité
quasi parfaite sur le papier entre la
gauche et la droite avant le deuxè Tour
qu'est-ce qui va faire pencher la
balance dimanche prochain selon vous
on les voit on a une légère avance à
gauche qu'est-ce qui va faire prancher
la balance c'est d'abord une
mobilisation de notre électorat un
rassemblement des forces de gauche et du
centre car vous savez après les deux
mandats de la majorité départementale
avec l'action que nous avons mené cette
solidarité permanente sur les
territoires
l'électorat si on repositionne le
l'élection c'est-à-dire à l'échelon
départemental l'électorat va nous
rejoindre pour atteindre cette majorité
vous êtes certain du soutien des
candidats du Front de Gauche
oui dans ces temps difficile la gauche
sait se
retrouver encore une fois la politique
que nous avons mené durant ces dernières
années est une politique de solidarité
politique de gauche nous avions un un
camarade disons communiste dans dans nos
rangs et sa voix n'a jamais failli donc
nous pouvons parler à l'ensemble du
peuple de gauche oui une réaction sur la
les difficultés de Rémy chintron dans
son canton il est Président c'est un
canton emblématique aussi en Bresse
oui bien sûr notre président est en
difficulté ceci dit laissons encore se
déroul cette semaine où peut-être que
son électorat les enfin les habitants de
ce canton euh disons prendront
conscience de de l'action qu'il a mené
euh tant en en tant que que premier
vice-président qu'ensuite président à la
tête de ce département il nous a
vraiment tiré vers le haut par
l'innovation par des mesures concrètes
pour pour nos citoyens et et ça je pense
qu'après c'est vrai la la surprise de ce
score euh hier je pense que les
habitants du canton de Louin vont se
ressaisir et et et vont dire non on
garde notre président et au cas où en en
un mot vous avez un président ou une
présidente de
rechange vous savez chaque chose en son
temps après le premier tour pour
l'instant il n'y a que trois conseillers
trois binômes d'élus sur les 29 donc ça
fait ça fait 10 % donc pour l'instant
travaillons dans chaque canton pour pour
gagner ces élections et pour arriver à
la majorité minimum donc 15 binôes voire
16 merci Jean-Luc fonra en direct du
creusau pour cette réaction nous allons
partir pour Maon cette foisù nous attend
le secrétaire départemental du Front
national en sonellloir Sébastien àouin
bonjour Sébastien àouin on entend parler
de la poussée de votre parti dans
certains départements peut-être dans une
moindre mesure en sonloir par rapport à
alonne ou la
Nièvre non après nous pouvons toujours
être satisfaits quand même du résultat
que nous avons fait sur la sonéloire
nous avions misé sur 10 binôes au second
tour le résultat nous en sommes à 13
dont h triangulaires le Front national
se trouve aussi dans CIN duels donc deux
de la majorité sortante et deux contre
enfin trois contre la droite après nous
pouvons voir aussi que la chapelle de
ginchet où le Front National est sorti
largement en tête ne faut il ne faut pas
oublier aussi Chalon sur sa enfin Chalon
Chalon 1 où le Front national est arrivé
en tête nous faisons des très bons
scores nous améliorons encore les scores
par rapport aux européennes donc nous
pouvons être que très satisfaits pour
l'instant euh des résultats du pour le
second tour qui s'annonce pour dimanche
en sonoir en même temps Marine Le Pen
annoncé le Front national comme premier
parti de France en tout cas en sonéloir
ce n'est pas le cas vous êtes derrière
le bloc de gauche et derrière le bloc de
droite c'est un Paris raté pour vous
quand même ou pas non ce n'est pas un
pari raté nous sur la Sonel noire nous
avions misé sur 20 % donc pour une
grande majorité des candidats nous avons
atteint les 20 % donc euh pour nous déjà
le bilan il est déjà très concluant et
sur les triangulaire il y en a huit vous
l'avez rappelé vous vous maintenez
partout tout à fait oui le Front
national ne fera aucune alliance il ne
se désistera pas euh nous serons
présents sur les euh les huit
triangulaires le Front national jouera
le rôle d'arbitre pour certains canton
et après sur sur d'autres nous espérons
quand même remporter la victoire
lesquels euh comme Pierre de Bray ça se
joue dans un mouchoir de de poche nous
avons d'autres cantons où la gauche est
mal menée et la droite aussi donc là
nous allons repartir sur le terrain très
rapidement nous allons faire revenir le
maximum
d'abstentionnistes car il faut pas
oublier que suite à la déclaration
d'Emmanuel Vals hier soir que ça soit la
droite ou la gauche qui gagne rien ne
sera changé sur la politique mené
nationalement donc c'est-à-dire encore
plus d'austérité encore moins de
dotation au départ
voir la disparition du département donc
nous nous serons là nous allons défendre
le département jusqu'au bout et nous
appelons donc tous les abstentionnistes
à rejoindre enfin voter Front national
car si on vote à droite ou à gauche rien
ne change et bien autant raorter le
changement avec le Front national
Sébastien alouin pour le Front national
en direct de Macon merci à vous voilà
pour ce chapitre sur la sonéire passons
à Lyonne à présent illustration de la
poussée justement de ce parti le Front
national dans le canton de Joigny par
exemple il arrive en tête et devant le
Parti socialiste de 4 voix FN PS au
second tour c'est le cas dans trois
cantons de ce département la droite
partie divisé avec de listes é vincé Tho
Soum et Claude HE sont qualif pour le de
tour et franiseour
etcas la gauche contre le Front national
dans le canton de Jo les résultats se
sont fait attendre mais ils sont
cinglant pour l'UMP et l'UDI qui avan au
premier tour pourtant à 18h au début du
dépouillement Nicolas der avait des
raisons d'y croire pour le moment on
serait sur un duel le PS UMP surtout pas
jouer à Madame Irma mais dans mon bureau
là à l'heure actuelle ce serait ça si en
effet sur la ville de joigi l'UMP arrive
2e derrière la gauche c'était oublié la
partie rurale du canton où de nombreux
villages ont placé le Front national en
tête une tendance confirmée dans la
soirée le FN est premier sur le canton
avec 31,3 % sont des suffrages et quatre
voies d'avance sur la gauche aujourd'hui
ce monde rural se sent totalement
déshérité totalement abandonné que ce
soit sur le plan de l'agriculture que ce
soit sur le plan des services publics
que ce soit sur le plan des personnes
âgées aujourd'hui un sentiment
d'abandon et je pense que Marine Le Pen
les candidats du Front national moi-même
et Mademoiselle Dior nous serons demain
à la fois des por-voies et puis
également des acteurs pour aider le
monde rural pour ol S et Françoise rour
binô de gauche qualifié le score élevé
de l'extrême droite doit inciter les
électeurs à se mobiliser au second tour
on ne connaît pas les candidats du Front
national nous n'avons jamais vu la
candidate du Front national elle n'a pas
mis les pieds sur le territoire durant
toute cette campagne nous ne la
connaissons pas qui peut porter nos
dossiers lourds et importants au
département pour 6 ans dans 7 jours il
n'y a que Françoise R et moi qui soyons
en capacité de le faire la droite
sortante paye sa division au prix fort é
VC ds le prier tour c'est sûr que si on
s'était entendu peut-être que nous n'en
serions pas là bon maintenant on peut
pas revenir en arrière sur ce qui a été
fait j'avais dit précédemment que
j'étais pas pour les extrêmes donc je
continue à dire que je ne suis pas pour
les extrêmes donc voilà donc après
comprendra qui voudra comprendre mais
voilà de son côté le binôme UMP indique
ce soir ne pas donner de consigne de
vote pour ce second tour inédit à
joigni après Joanny d'autres résultats
dans lonne avec vous Elsa oui
illustration de cette vague bleu marine
avec C cantons le Front National a des
chances de gagner le FN pourrait prendre
charn si l'électorat gauche éluminé ne
se déplace pas aux urnes situation
identique à migène avec un duel UMP
Front National au 2ème tour à l'extrême
droite en ballottage favorable aussi à
Brinon sur armençon le FN qui arrive en
tête on vous en a beaucoup parlé hier
aussi à ponturyon le binôme Odou Ferrand
obtient une large avance sur la gauche
et sur la droite ce sera l'une des
quatre triangulaires incertaines
dimanche prochain plusieurs duels entre
le FN et la droite exemple la joue la
ville où le président sortant du conseil
général l'UDI André Villier arrive en
tête devant le tandem frontiste à droite
le sénateur UMP Jean-Baptiste Lemoine
fait mieux puisqu'il est le seul élu dès
le premier tour dans le département avec
Delphine gremis c'est dans le canton de
gaâtiné en Bourgogne et de ce fait il
prend l'ascendant dans la course à la
présidence du département en revanche et
c'est le dernier résultat rude soirée
pour la gauche dans Lyonne même dans son
bastion d'Avallon le duo PS se classe 3e
et se retrouve engagé dans une
triangulaire à haut risque au deuxème
tour le barrage au Front national c'est
ce que l'on a entendu beaucoup hier soir
l'appel à faire barrage avec des
consignes parfois pas forcément très
claires du Nini du comprendra qui pourra
André Villier le président sortant udi
lui est beaucoup plus clair il appelle à
un front républicain donc à voter
clairement pour la gauche face au FN on
écoute j'appelle
clairement lorsque les candidats de
gauche dans le département seront
opposés au Front national appelle les
forces de droite c'est-à-dire de l'UMP
et du centre droit à voter pour le
candidat de gauche qui sera opposé au
Front national nous sommes en situation
parfois qui nécessitera des accords avec
des désistement de gauche et que je
pense qu'il y a là la une bonne manière
en tout cas
républicaine qui va bien au-delà
d'ailleurs de la dimension républicaine
pour ce qui me concerne puisque c'est
plus un attachement éthique et et
philosophique à la chose publique qui me
conduit à à demander aux électeurs de
droite et du centre droit dès lors
qu'ils ne seront plus représentés par un
candidat et bien de se mobiliser pour le
candidat de gauche contre le candidat du
Front National et nous restons dans
Lyonne direction Auer où nous attend
Jean-Baptiste Lemoine sénateur élu UMP
élu donc dans le canton gaâtinant en
Bourgogne au premier tour hier vous avez
entendu André Villier Jean-Baptiste
Solomon et cette consigne clair vous
partagez l'AVE d'André
Villier bah je crois que surtout euh la
question va être posé à la gauche parce
que j'appelle votre attention sur le
fait que il y a deux triangulaires à
haut risque à ponturon et à Avallon où
nous avons des candidats de grande
qualité et pour l'instant nous n'avons
pas de retrait des candidats de gauche
arrivés 3è et et et donc la question se
pose aux étatmajors de gauche de savoir
ce qu'ils font parce que c'est bien beau
d'avoir des paroles à Paris mais nous
attendons les actes sur le terrain après
je vais vous dire s'agissant de de de la
situation les choses sont claires il
faut euh tout simplement faire confiance
au candidats et bien qui est le plus
engagé localement le le parce qu'on a
bien vu que c'était un cri de détresse
qui était lancé à travers ce ce vote
protestataire et donc pour résoudre un
cri de détresse quoi de mieux que des
hommes et des femmes qui sont investis
dans les associations investis dans
leurs communes dans les
intercommunalités et qui sont là au
quotidien pour accompagner et être au
côté de celles et ceux qui travaillent
qui parfois peuvent souffrir et en tous
les cas qui ont exprimé un grand ralbol
Jean-Baptiste Lemoine c'est un secret
pour personne que dans la coulisse on
disait que vous étiez intéressé
éventuellement par la présidence du
conseil général à la place d'André
Villier si l'évolution de l'élection le
permettait est-ce que vous êtes toujours
dans cette situation au soir du premier
tour vous êtes le premier
élu alors attendez euh je suis ravi
d'être le premier élu avec Delphine
Gremy nous sommes deux euh nous en
remercions les les iconnais pour ma part
c'est la troisième fois en un an qu'ils
me font massivement confiance et
vraiment je les remercie du fond du cœur
maintenant le sujet c'est pas ma petite
personne c'est pas la petite personne de
X ou Y on voit bien que le résultat qui
vient de de ce premier tour il impose
d'aller au résultat d'aller à
l'efficacité le le le message qui était
envoyé c'est vous les politiques
bougez-vous et donc moi je serai
vigilant à ce que dans la future
majorité de droite et du centre qui j'ai
j'espère verra le jour au terme du
deuxème tour et bien on puisse aller au
résultat à l'efficacité parce qu'il y a
un certain nombre de mesures qu'il
faudra qu'on prenne il y a une détresse
qui éta exprimée en matière de de
désertification médicale il y a une
détresse qui éta exprimée en matière
économique la préférence économique
locale c'est pas un 20 mots le
département il investit 30 millions
d'euros par an et bien nous on doit être
présent au rendez-vous pour faire en
sorte que les entrepreneurs de Lyonne
puissent bosser parce que effectivement
les camions qui font des milliers de
kilomètres et qui déversent des
travailleurs qui sont parfois fois
exploiter et ben ça fait ça fait
effectivement ça génère ce vote donc il
est important que le Conseil général se
mette pour ce nouveau mandat en tant que
conseil départemental et bien en ordre
de marche avec des élus compétents
déterminés renouvelés et qui on envie
d'une seule chose c'est faire réussir
Lyonne parce que c'est ça notre ambition
merci Jean-Baptiste leemin nous suivrons
donc le deème tour et le 3è puis qu'il y
a élection du président tout même on
aura noté qu'il n'est pas candidat mais
qu'il a quand même énoncé sa feuille de
route Jean-Baptiste Le Moine pour la
future majorité donc tout n'est pas
encore déterminé là-bas voilà voilà pour
Lyon à 13h20 édition spéciale sur France
vous le savez pour ces élections
départemental et nous partons pour le
département de la Nièvre seellement
autre maintenant autre département où le
FN peut jouer les troubles faites la
gauche pourrait passer de justesse par
exemple dans le canton de Corbini
territoire historiquement marqué à
gauche qui voit l'UMP et le FN s'invité
au 2ème tour pour une triangulaire
surprise résumé de cette soirée à
Corbini avec Pauline b et Romain
lib le rideau tombe sur le canton de
Corbini au fur et à mesure du
dépouillement l'hypothèse de la
triangulaire semble se profiler St le
candidat Front national Marcel Stéphan
se fait une place dans ce canton du
Morvent traditionnellement acquis à la
gauche l'UMP le PS et le FN se
retrouvent au deuxème tour pour une
triangulaire
inattendu bien évidemment la situation
aura été meilleure en en duel face à la
gauche évidemment mais bon monsieur
Bazin n'est pas élu au premier tour
comme c'était coutume
voilà c'est quand même nouveau et bon il
y aura un deè tour je sais pas
historiquement mais ça fait plusieurs
décennies que le candidat du canton de
l'or est lu au premier tour la donne
change pour Fabien Bazin le candidat PS
il arrive même derrière le candidat UMP
à quelques voix près 33,1 % pour
Jean-Charles Rochard 32,9 % pour Fabien
Bazin 25
%c St mais le conseiller sortant ne veut
pas dramatiser ses
résultats on est sur des territoires
différents on est sur une élection
différente il y a aujourd'hui deux
titulaires un homme et une femme on va
réaliser enfin la parité au sein de de
l'Assemblée départemental ce qui n'était
pas gagné si on était resté sur un autre
un autre mode de scrutin et puis on est
une période on le voit bien où il y a
une perte de sens de repère et notre
travail à nous les élus locaux bah c'est
justement de redonner ces repères et ce
sens parce que la République c'est aussi
celle des villages Jean-Charles Rochard
termine donc en tête de ce premier tour
mais il a affiché une humine inquiète
toute la soirée en attendant les
derniers résultats les triangulaires ne
sont jamais idéales parce que on ne peut
jamais savoir comment les
abstentionnistes comment les reports
vont pouvoir se réaliser c'est assez
compliqué ce que je note c'est que la
gauche était partie divisée et que de
nombreuses consignes venu du Front de
Gauche nous indiquaient qu'il refuserait
de se reporter sur le Parti socialiste
qui montre bien qu'il y a une véritable
désunion l'UMP compte sur cette division
de la gauche au premier tour pour gagner
ce canton le FN n'ayant que très peu de
chance de s'imposer dans cette
configuration et après Corbini d'autres
résultats dans la Nièvre avec vous els
Besin oui premier résultat d'abord à 9r2
le FIAF dans l'ancien ministre Pierre
bergovois où le FN opère une poussée
l'extrême droite vire en tête avec plus
de 30 % des suffrages à encore mais
cette fois 9h1 dans ce canton là c'est
le parti socialiste qui est devant la
liste PS qui sera opposée à une liste
sans étiquette acclam territoire marqué
à gauche et bien la gauche est éliminée
le canton tombera dans l'escarcelle de
la droite ou de l'extrême droite enfin
dans la Nièvre les regards se porteront
forcément sur Château Chinon les terres
de François mitteran le canton du
président sortant Patrice Jolie a priori
peu de suspense le socialiste fait la
course en tête nous disions terre de
gauche la Nièvre nous partons pour 9h
rejoindre François dio pour le parti
communiste François dio merci d'être
avec nous on on a évoqué cette montée du
Front national dans la Nièvre c'est un
grand écart du PC au FN dans certains
canton bah les résultats de ces
élections départementales sont un
nouveau signe de la catastrophe
politique dans laquelle s'enfonce la
Nièvre et le pays avec une une explosion
du du vote d'extrême droite une montée
des idées populistes un fort taux
d'abstention et ça c'est le résultat
direct d'une politique gouvernementale
qui désespère l'électorat de gauche et
qui nous amène à un scénario qui qui qui
qui nous inquiète fortement c'est le
scénario du pire qui se dessine donc il
y a un signe positif quand même dans
cette élection c'est les résultats des
candidats du Front de Gauche dans le
département de la niève qui sont les
seuls à résister et même à progresser
dans de très nombreux cantons on est à
12 % pour le Front de Gauche à la
proportionnelle il y aurait quatre élus
communistes à l'Assemblée départemental
donc nous on appelle évidemment à un
changement de cap gouvernemental pour
enfin redonner espoir à cet électorat de
gauche qui s'était pourtant massivement
mobilisé pour battre Nicolas Sarkozi et
cette nouvelle gauche il faut la la
construire avec toutes les les
sensibilités sincères de Gauche
communiste socialistes écologiste pour
éviter la catastrophe annoncée alors de
bons SCOR comme vous dites mais en même
temps aucun élu donc ou il y en aura un
mais le seul qui sera c'est un allié
d'une candidate socialiste euh donc
est-ce que vous appelez quand même
malgré tout à vootter pour les
socialistes malgré la politique
gouvernementale que vous
dénoncez dans dans le canton de varen
vosell c'est un cas particulier puisque
nous avons à faire à des socialistes qui
sont en rupture avec les orientations
gouvernementales actuell et c'est ce que
justement nous cherchons à construire
c'est-à-dire un rassemblement de toutes
celles et ceux qui restent fidèles aux
valeurs de gauche et qui veulent
reconstruire la gauche dans dans dans sa
globalité et dans les autres cantons
vous appelez à voter pour les candidats
de
socialistes pour pour pour nos appels de
le second tour c'est très clair nous ne
banaliserons jamais l'élection d'un
candidat du Front national donc barrage
au Front national nous appelons aussi à
battre la droite partout où elle est en
mesure de de de gagner un canton
puisqu'on sait que la droite loin de
combattre l'austérité veut en remettre
une couche et veut s'attaquer à tous les
mécanismes de solidarité construits par
les majorités de gauche ceci dit notre
appel est un appel exigeant envers tous
les candidats de gauche puisque le
soutien à la politique gouvernementale
ça n'est pas le sens de de notre appel
bien au contraire le le sens de notre
appel c'est la construction d'une
résistance et de la reconstruction de
d'une d'une d'un rassemblement
anti-austérité antiréforme territoriale
et fidèle aux valeurs de gauche c'est ça
l'avenir de la gauche c'est pas le
suivisme de la politique gouvernemental
et nous appelons les candidats
socialistes présents au deème tour à
s'engager sur cette voie-là c'est la
voix de la victoire au vu des résultats
du premier tour merci François du en
direct de Never dernier département
celui de la Côte d'Or dans un instant un
débat sur le canton de Montbar mais
d'abord les principaux résultats avec
vous Elsa avec d'abord le canton de
Châtillon sur scèneù le seul canton à
avoir un tandem élu dès le premier tour
Valérie Bouchard et le maire UMP Hubert
Brigan l'emporte avec plus de 52 % des
suffrages le Front national gagne du
terrain à brasé en pleine il bascule
même en tête avec 39 % des voix mettant
en difficulté les tendems de droite et
de gauche l'extrême droite devant aussi
dans le fief de la gauche chenauve avec
un duel qui s'annonce très serré la
gauche elle résiste bien dans la
capitale régionale en ballotage plus ou
moins favorable dans cinq des cantons
dijonnais notamment Dijon 2 où le maire
Alain Millot et sa première adjointe ont
pris une belle avance face à la droite à
ce mur en nousoie large avantage pour le
président udi sortant François Sauvadet
il est contint un 2uxème tour face à
l'extrême droite mais il devrait
logiquement garder son fauteuil la
droite de François Sauvadet qui étant
son influence dans le canton de Montbar
Marc fro et Laurence sport sont en
ballotage favorable face au radicau de
gauche Marion montouachon et Patrick
Molin et nous poursuivons la discussion
sur la Côte d'Or que connaissent bien
nos invités Alain sugn et Michel neot
une question d'abord pour Alain
SuG globalement on sait que la droite
est majoritaire au Conseil Général de
Côte d'Or la majorité ne changera pas
néanmoins si on regarde les chiffres et
les blocs on s'aperçoit que finalement
la droite n'a pas progressé par rapport
à une élection cantonale comme celle de
2011 qui à l'époque avait quand même pas
été un moment favorable 38 % pour la
droite en 2011 en Côte d'Or 38,4 hier
soir est-ce qu'on doit corréler ça avec
les 27 % du Front national sur le
département de la Côte d'Or en gros
est-ce que c'est le Front National qui
vous scotche et qui vous empêche de
progresser je crois que c'était la
manœuvre y compris du Premier ministre
c'était de faire qu'à travers un vote de
mécontentement on puisse empêcher une
alternance c'est probablement un des
enjeux des mois et des années qui
viennent donc c'est raison pour laquelle
on peut avoir de discours mais le
discours de dire on dénonce le Front
National et on ne retire pas forcément
les candidats contrairement à ce qu'on a
entendu compris dans d'autres
départements fonctionne à plein donc
c'est raison pour lesquelle l'umpudi
font un très bon score faut pas non plus
minimiser cette fois-ci ce score il
nottion score que une élection lequel
c'était un vote sanction invers avec un
vote de premier tour entre guillemets de
de je disais tout à l'heure un vote de
de souffrance puisque quand la France va
mal l'électorat y compris de droite va
mal aussi donc dans ces condition iition
je pense que le premier tour c'est pour
ça qu'il faut appeler à mobiliser bien
sûr au deième tour et notamment les
abstentionnistes qui n'ont pas été votés
parce qu'il y a aussi un électorat de
droite qui n'a pas été voté qui dans ses
conditions a aussi mal qui est confronté
au chômage et le Parti socialiste assume
bien sûr cette responsabilité donc il
faut bien ne pas se tromper de cible et
je crois qu'un vote Front national on le
sait bien aboutit purement et simplement
à faire que les socialistes conservent
quelquefois des sièges et c'est bien sûr
le message qu' faut faire passer
aujourd'hui je pense notamment à bras et
en pleine hein ne n tromprons pas je
crois que il faut bien sûr une grande
mobilisation sur bras et en pleine pour
au candidats Emmanuel coin et et Gill de
LEP il faut aussi an Nui saint-georgees
parce que là on le dit pas trop mais
quand on connaît effectivement le
candidat socialiste sortant le fait
qu'il soit en difficulté aujourd'hui
c'est bien évident la preuve que l'UMP
l'UDI progresse il n'empêche que les
triangulaires du Front national n'ent
pas bien sûr à ce que la majorité le
premier parti de France aujourd'hui l'
MP l'UDI puisse dès le premier tour
obtenir bien sûr satisfaction et déjà
des victoires Michel not la gauche perd
15 points quand même sur le département
par rapport à la dernière élection
quanton surtout au milieu r est-ce que
la gauche n'a pas délaissé le milieu
rural comme on l'entend beaucoup
notamment de la part desond de point il
y a ce que l'on déclare et il y a la
tête que l'on fait quand je vois la tête
des candidats de droite de côes d'or
hier soir ici même quand je vois ce que
l'on vient d'entendre j'ai pas
l'impression que la tête des candidats
droite ce soit la tête de la victoire
ils sont très surpris du score de la
gauche deuxièmement effectivement très
grande progression du vote FN
dans le milieu rural et là je dis
attention qui SIME le vent récolte la
tempête tout les encouragements au
discours qui dit la campagne est morte
la campagne ne s'en occupe pas la
campagne est la délaissé le discours
porté par la majorité départementale en
code d'or partout hein il y en a que
pour Dijon et on délaisse la campagne
c'est un peu ça quand même hein ce n'est
pas du tout ça dans la réalité des
choses et vous comme mère de B si vousz
ne vous plaez pas hein
donc c'est bien c'est bien le discours
qui est porté par la droite
départementale et qui amène
naturellement cette désespérance alors
que le sort qui est fait en matière de
service public en matière d'aide en
matière de financement au milieu rural
et aux antipodes de l'image que l'on
veut en donner mal de l'image que de
l'image que l'on veut en donner voilà
donc ce qui est important aussi pour ce
deuxème tour c'est effectivement être
clair sur les principes monsieur ver
était très clair une grande partie de la
droite n'est pas claire dessus nous
notre principe est le suivant notre
ennemi c'est le FN parce que le FN c'est
la suppression du vivre ensemble et
notre adversaire localement en CODOR
puisqu'on parle de CODOR c'est la droite
parce qu'elle n'a pas assumé les
compétences de solidarité comme elle
aurait dû le faire dans le moment de
crise que vivent les C de rien merci
Michel merci à d'être venu ce midi sur
France 3 Bourgogne nous allons pour
poursivre avec la CODOR et le canton de
Montbar avec un débat dans un instant
avec deux invités à votre place Laurence
sport et Patrick molinau d'abord la
situation à Montbar la gauche en
difficulté Laurent sport donc est devant
Patrick Molinoz après ce premier tour
vous le voyez avec ces chiffre près de
36 % pour le duo formé par Laurence
sport et Marc fro reportage de François
Latour et Jean-François guilm hier soir
à Montbar alors que les derniers
électeurs du centreeville viennent faire
leur choix le dépouillement des ures va
ensuite donner la tendance pour la ville
fro porte le bino mudi Laurence porte
Marc fro se distingueent nettement les
suffrages des autres communes du canton
vont réduire l'écart avec le binôme du
PRG 223 voix vont séparer les deux bords
pour la M udi de Montbar c'est bien la
proximité qui a joué en sa faveur sur le
terrain finalement en tant qu'élu bah
c'est pas que le temps de la campagne
électorale c'est tout le temps moi je
suis tout le temps sur le terrain et bah
c'est c'est ça c'est ça la faire de la
politique au sens noble c'est vraiment
être à l'écoute être dans la dans
l'écoute des besoins des attentes du
territoire et c'est vrai que le moment
de la campagne électorale permet de
vraiment écouter les besoins qui
s'expriment de façon plus plus
importante je dirais parce qu'ils sont
cristallisés par le moment de la
campagne électorale mais ce qu'on fait
pendant le temps d'une campagne
électorale finalement c'est le travail
qui est conduit sur sur un mandat hein
c'est c'est le terrain à Montbar on a
voté plus qu'ailleurs 57 % de
participation soit 7 points de plus que
la moyenne nationale pour Patrick
Molinos conseiller sortant PRG de
l'ancien canton de venar et Llum
l'affrontement sera serré et se jouera
entre les deux tours on a de points et
demi hein de retard ce qui n'est rien et
qu'on compte bien d'ici le deuxème tour
mobiliser largement et puis montrer que
le le travail de proximité de deux
candidats qui sont réellement implantés
sur le canton et qui n'ont pas un pied
en dehors de ce canton et un pied dans
ce canton comme le binôme adverse
qualifié pour le second tour est le bon
binôme pour défendre et et représenter
les habitants du canton de Montbar
venarel etom le premier tour à Montbar
se conclut donc sur un duel en excluant
le Front National qui n'a pas souhaité
commenter ce résultat nous étions donc
hier soir au côté des candidats de
Montbar Laurence sportte et Patrick
Molino sont avec nous Laurence sportte
bonjour bonjour candidat donc arrivé en
tête avec votre binô udi UMP Patrick
Molino pour le PRG bonjour bonjour
arrivé donc 2e vous serez opposé tout à
au second tour dimanche prochain et opp
POS débat dès maintenant dans ce débat
sur France 3 Bourgogne avec vous Lilian
met éc SIO euh Patric Molino est-ce que
vous vous considérez dans une situation
difficile après ce premier tour il y a
pas de candidat au soir d'une élection
qui veut admettre que les choses sont
pas au niveau qu'il espérait moi je
trouve que c'est toujours un peu langue
de bois j'aurais préféré être devant
maintenant je pense que les réserves de
voix sont plutôt de notre côté donc moi
je suis confiant je suis confiant dans
le travail qu'on a qu'on a réalisé mais
il y a sans doute encore plus
d'explications à donner pour
effectivement dire que ce département il
peut être plus plus solidaire et plus
efficace qu'il n'est Laurence sportte
donc vous êtes au coude à coude j'allais
dire bon vous avez une une légère avance
est-ce que vous aussi vous considérez
que vous avez une réserve de voie
notamment est-ce que vous appelez les
gens qui ont voté pour le duel le duo
pardon pénac péri a vootter pour votre
propre binôme même s'il était soutenu
par alainouper on le sait ce que
j'aimerais avant toute chose exprimer
c'est que euh nous sommes nous étions
les outsiders sur sur cette élection
pour le premier tour nous arrivons à
faire la course en tête ce qui est quand
même une très bonne chose en ayant
largement aussi conforté notre score sur
Montbar en ayant aussi un excellent
score sur le rural et ça c'est le fruit
de notre travail d'équipe de candidats
de terrain et qui sont des candidats
locaux dans leur ensemble alors ce que
j'ai envie de dire par rapport à la
réserve que vous é que vous évoquez
c'est tout simplement que moi moi
j'appelle les électeurs et bien après
avoir exprimé un vote contestataire fort
de mécontentement en direction des
instances nationales et bien c'est
maintenant de de de reporter tout cela
sur un vote utile utile pour les actions
du quotidien de proximité que doivent
conduire le département on doit
comprendre que vous englobez dans ces
voix ces électeurs les
1656 électeurs qui ont voté pour le
Front national sur votre canton aussi
moi je m'adresse à absolument tous les
électeurs je crois qu'il faut prendre en
considération le signal très fort qui
est envoyé qui est envoyé de dans de
tout dans tout le pays au gouvernement
qui nous a imposé une réforme qui nous a
imposé un mode de scrutin qui ne nous a
jamais consulté qui a même été je je
paèse mes mots qui a été même jusqu'à
voilà nous mettre dans une situation
d'élection et vous en conviendrez
monsieur Molino alors que la loi n'est
même pas définitivement calé enfin je
crois qu'on a absolument jamais vu ça
question du FR national c'est pas la
réforme notre les électeurs du Front
national j'ai envie de dire les
électeurs au sens
large l'électorat il est ce qu'il est
les gens ils expriment ce qu'ils ont
envie d'exprimer c'est la démocratie et
moi je fais un appel vraiment au votes
utile au vote des hommes et des femmes
qui ont envie tout simplement d'avoir
des conseillers départementaux qui les
représentent efficacement et sans aucune
arrogance surtout monsieur Molinos vous
ne regrettez pas de ne pas avoir fait
alliance avec le par socialiste d'avoir
notamment une binô on pensait beaucoup à
Christel Sylvestre l'ancien maire de
Montbas et d'être parti sans eux mais
moi j'ai toujours fait campagne au
cantonnal d'abord je veux dire je suis
un peu surpris de l'appel du pied plus
que fort que vient de faire la candidate
du 2ème tour à l'électorat Front
national il y a un vrai sujet avec nos
concitoyens qui globalement rejette un
système et qui en réalité entend les
sirènes de ceux qui disent à l'UMP ils
sont mauvais au Parti socialiste à l' MP
l'UD ils sont mauvais au Parti
socialiste PRG et ailleurs ils sont
mauvais aussi donc essayer la nouvelle
marque même si nous n'avons aucun aucun
programme et il suffit pas de dire le
Front national c'est l'ennemi comme
certains disent ou faire des appels du
pied comme je viens de l'entendre au
Front national il faut dire quelle
réponse on apporte aux gens qui sont en
désespérance aux classes moyennes aux
ouvriers aux employés à tous ces gens
qui ont l'impression c'est plus qu'une
impression que aujourd'hui on on leur
prend le peu qu'ils ont alors que des
gens très aisés voient leur situation
s'améliorer d'année en année alors que
est-ce vous pensez que la gauche ne
parle pas aux gens des zones rurales
c'est un message que vous avez tenu au
conseil général contre une partie de
votre propre camp pendant une certaine
période moi j'étais contre je suis un
élu rural qui défend le rural qui est
conseiller général depuis 13 ans qui a
monté des projets sur sa communauté de
commune sur sa commune moi je suis pas
là pour me payer de mots certains on
nous promettent un avenir
très bien bon ils viennent d'être élus
on verra dans 6 ans si ils sont capables
de faire ce qu'ils annoncent je respecte
tout à fait ça moi mais pour ce qui me
concerne nous avons un véritable bilan
des choses que nous avons réellement
conduite faite au service des gens au
service de la petite enfance au service
des familles au service des seniors et
c'est cette proximité ce travail de de
lien quotidien que je conduis depuis
depuis 13 ans maintenant que que nous
voulons que nous voulons pour suivre
tout simplement sur quel thème vous
allez faire campagne entre les deux
tours là pendant cette semaine pour
rallier justement les les les électeurs
qui n'ont pas votter pour vous mais moi
j'aimerais quand même rebondir sur ce
que dit Monsieur Molino je rappelle
quand même que sur les anciens cantons
de Montbar et vénaret on avait deux
conseillers généraux de gauche donc
voilà notre score est d'autant plus
significatif et que les forces de PR
vous avez un conseiller sortant dans
votre binôme qui a aussi une certaine
notoriété en particulier dans le monde
rural tout à fait exactementés
important quand on sait pardonnez-moi
que le Conseil Général distribue
beaucoup de subvencure défenseur actif
du monde rural en effet le monde le
monde agricole il est essentiel aussi à
notre tissu économique rural et moi
j'aimerais bien aussi connaître votre
position de façon claire et nette sur
l'accord cadre envers les agriculteurs
par exemple donc on est sur sur un
canton où nous avons réussi à établir un
excellent score je constate que les
forces de de progrès n on n'ont pas
réussi à porter le combat de la ruralité
qui suffit pas d'être le chentre de la
ruralité sur le terrain et puis parfois
à Dijon voilà de pas avoir des positions
tout à fait claires sure le débat madame
porte c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
écoutez monsieur alors vous voulez me
donner des leç je vous donne pas des
leçons vous ne pouvez pas dire vous ne
pouvez pas dire non non parce que vous
dites des choses qui sont fausses donc
moi à Dijons j'ai toujours défendu la
ruralité et le canton de venar l'OM y
compris parfois contre ma famille
politique effectivement cette réforme
moi je ne l'ai pas soutenu euh les
radicaux de gauche ne l'ont pas soutenu
euh mais aujourd'hui le débat n'est pas
la réforme elle a eu lieu le découpage
il est ce qu'il est et on doit
maintenant se retrousser les manches
continuer de travailler je soulligne
également vous dites qu'il y avait deux
conseillers généraux de gauche qui est
vrai dans nos deux anciens cantons mais
dans une majorité de droite qui a
augmenté de 25 % les impôts en 6 ans qui
a diminué de moitié les crédits aux
routes vous me demandez quelle est ma
position sur l'accord cadre sur
l'agriculture mais bon elle est très CLA
il y a un travail fait entre la Chambre
d'Agriculture c'est les professionnels
les agriculteurs eux-mêmes et le Conseil
général une fois que le point
d'équilibre est trouvé et bien on le
respecte tout simplement donc moi je
suis dans un travail réel avec des vrais
résultat après on peut faire de la
polémique moi c'est pas mon style c'est
pas jamais la manière dont j'ai dont
j'ai voulu travailler donc moi je veux
continuer de travailler pour pour les
habitants du canton de Montbar et de
venar et léum et c'est comme ça qu'on
fera avancer les choses dans une logique
de de respect et de
solidarité donc pour répondre à votre
question sur la stratégie à venir et
bien nous allons donc défendre continuer
de rester nous-mêm avant toute chose et
continuer à défendre un programme
d'action réaliste réalisable et non pas
un catalogue de promesses complètement
démagogique financièrement intenable qui
ne respecte ni les électeurs ni les
contributeurs donc c'est un petit peu
facile voilà de se poser toujours en
victime mais la réalité elle est là les
gens ne veulent plus entendre de
promesses ils veulent aussi des élus de
terrain des élus aussi qui n'ont pas
fait de la politique leur métier voilà
qui ont une autre façon d'aborder les
choses et qui ont pour ambition d'être à
l'écoute au côté des gens avec aussi des
permanences hein je crois que c'est
aussi c'est ça c'est aussi une ambition
c'est une ambition réelle de proximité
on est vraiment dans le contact sur le
terrain et je crois que c'est ce que
veulent les gens en tout cas c'est ce
qu'ils nous disent quand nous les
rencontrons le procès en ambition pardon
mais il me semble que vous aviez fait
campagne en disant que vous vous
consacreriez totalement uniquement à la
ville de Montbar bon le champ est en
train de s'élargir moi je respecte ça il
y a pas de souci puis pour la proximité
quand même permettez-moi de le rappeler
votre binô mais moi je respecte hein
mais je dis les choses telles qu'elles
sont votre binô est composé d'un homme
qui est premier adjoint sur le canton de
beignolé Juifs qui est conseiller
communautaire de la Communauté de
Commune du châtillonnis qui n'a aucune
aucun lien concret d'activité sur le
canton de Montbar àésia
effectivement vous connaissez mal vous
connaissez mal votre canton vous
connaissez mal votre canton et ça c'est
absolument reg suis né j'y vis depuis 45
ans AR 10 an vous connaissez très mal
puisque Marc FR est représentant du
conseil d'administration du collège
alisia c'est un agriculteur qui a des
terr sur V éé s en 2008 a des TER qui a
des terr sur votre con il faut expliquer
au téléspectateurs que le centre
d'interprétation d'alisia est sur votre
canton c'est le Gross dossier du conseil
général des dernières années c'est
quelque chose de d'envergure quand on a
organisé des débats sur le département
de la Côte d'Or ce qui a fait polémique
entre les participants c'est ce que ça
coûte actuellement en fonctionnement au
Conseil Général de Côte d'Or on sait que
la subvention d'équilibre être plus de 3
millions c'était pas ce qui était prévu
au départ en gros parce que c'est à peu
près ce qui était prévu au départ ouais
alors c'est il semble que ce soit quand
même beaucoup est-ce que de votre point
de vue à tous les deux c'est intéressant
c'est le rôle d'un conseil général
maintenant départemental de faire ner un
lieu touristique emblématique comme
celui-là écoutez pour moi c'est simple
alia était un projet qui a été décidé à
l'unanimité des conseillers généraux
avant même mon élection puisque c'était
en 1999- 2000 les premières
délibérations les plus les plus
importantes aujourd'hui c'est presque 70
personnes qui travaillent soit en direct
soit via des entreprises privées autour
du muséo parc c'est le 3ème site le plus
attractif touristiquement en cô d'or et
quand on a la chance d'avoir sur un
territoire comme le nôtre un outil de
développement économique un outil
également de patrimoine et de culture on
doit tout faire pour qu'il fonctionne et
le déficit de fonctionnement il était
prévu depuis le départ il est peut-être
un peu supérieur aujourd'hui à ce qui
était imaginé sans doute on peut mieux
gérer certainement il faut vraiment s'en
occuper et moi donc soutien de votre
part soutien aussi de la vote même si ça
coûte un peu d'argent mais
l'investissement du muséo parc
alaésisien c'est typiquement justement
l'exemple de la solidarité territoriale
qui s'est exprimé au travers des choix
de la majorité départementale à savoir
doter la Haute Côte d'Or d'un équipement
important important sur le plan
économique qui voilà est devenu le
troisème site le plus visité et on ne
peut que que regretter finalement que
l'État aujourd'hui la région ne suivent
pas du tout le projet et c'est fort
dommageable parce que là il y a
justement une volonté de rééquilibrage
de l'offre touristique et au-delà bien
sûr économique au travers de toutes les
retombées indirectes que peut générer
une aussi belle structure que le muséop
parc Alésia même si à priori ce ne c'est
pas dans la compéten de base d'un
conseil départemental ça fait partie des
compétences optionnelles hein une action
sur le plan de l'économie de
l'agriculture voilà c'est un choix qui
est assumé et qui permet justement
l'expression de cette solidarité
territoriale entre le monde rural et
puis les l'axe plus urbain on a aussi
besoin bien sûr d'avoir une métropole
forte Dijon et du reste on renvoie
l'ascenseur en participant notamment à
la lino au contournement de Ba entre
autres mais surtout àia àia c'est unique
en France c'est unique en Europe c'est
le patrimoine de notre pays et nous
avons le bonheur la chance de l'avoir
sur notre territoire il faut le faire
fructifier quand à vous entendre quand à
vous entend madame porte vous réjouir de
la rocade de
baun alors qu'il y a déjà un autoroute
avec deux sorties je trouve typiquement
que ça fait partie des investissements
mal venus du Conseil Général de la
cô une petite chose parce que vous
parliez en 10 secondes de solidarité de
choix nationaux moi j'aimerais bien aim
aussi entendre monsieur Molin exprimer
son positionnement sur
l'éducation cette fois-ci mais évidment
l' l'entend pas sur ces question
fondamentales qui rel
conseartition spécialeue sur France 3.fr
retrouver tous les résultats bien
évidemment dans votre canton nous nous
donons rendez-vous ce soir dans le 191
sur France 3 Bourgogne merci de votre
fidélité et très bel après-midi sur
France
[Musique]